expect all kinds of spellbinding fashion
when charmed returns on the CW we t
online Liana Galera was invited to the
Vancouver set where she surprised the
new trio of bewitching beauties with a
blessing from original charmer shannen
doherty I think it's awesome I'm happy
to see that a show that back then was
all about strong women who supported and
loved each other is now coming back
again I wish them well and he's so
that's just amazing I'm really grateful
that she's she sees Dawn's you know he's
finding the positives in him because I
think there are many the highly
anticipated reboot of the series that
premiered 20 years ago may have a whole
new cast but fans will be happy to know
it pays homage to its magical roots
first just like the original this 2018
version is about three enchanting
sisters who discover their witches
good thing we're witches not vampires
and just like the original the fashion
is to die for
though crop tops give way to
asymmetrical skirts in this version be
honest how often do you find yourself
wanting to walk off set while still in
costumes every day I mean my wardrobe is
like insane I lie and say were wrong and
Gucci I do have quite a few like 75
outfits that yes I grow on me I
consistently want to take all of my
clothes like I'm like in any way can I
borrow this like where did you get it
can invite but most importantly while
these witches battle demons and ghosts
just like their predecessors they still
believe in the magic of sister her I
really do feel like we're creating a
strong show and it's a fun show and I
think whether you're the og fan or a new
fan I think there's something for
everyone
is stronger than your sisterhood now as
for any possible cameo from any of the
original cast members we'll never say
never unless you are Alyssa Milano who
told us that ship has sailed
[Music]